اهلا وسهلا بك السيد الياس حنا ما اهميه
هذه الصواريخ
محمد اولا هي صواريخ بعيده المدى ليست ذات
راس كما ورد في التقرير هي قنابل عنقوديه
تتراوح عدد القنابل الصغيره فيها بين 350
و950
قنبله صغيره وهذا الامر يجب ان نعرف يعني
هل
الاتاكارس الجديد هو لسبعين كيلو متر او
لثلاث مئه كيلو متر هذا امر مهم جدا ولكن
انا اعتقد ان هذه الاسلحه اذا كانت المدى
البعيد هي ليست مهمه اذا كانت عنقوديه
بينما مهمه اذا استهدفت مراكز اساسيه في
العمق الروسي من هنا تمرير هذا الموضوع
البيت الابيض يبدو يبدو حذرا في تاكيد هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل برايك لماذا
انا اعتقد ان هناك نمط معين من السلوك لدى
البيت الابيض يعني يمرر الخبر وبعدها يتم
تخطي الخطوط الحمر التي وضعتها روسيه من
الى الهايمرز الى الدبابه الى المدفعيه
ومن ثم الى الابسط عشر هناك خطوط حمر
كثيره محمد تم تجاوزها ونحن اليوم في هذه
المرحله من المراحل يعني بين الستورم شادو
وسكلب الفرنسي واستنشدوا الانجليزي مسافه
250 كم هذا امر مهم جدا خرق الكثير من
الخطوط الحمر فلماذا لا يكون من ضمن هذه
الخطوط في كل مره اعمده الياس حنا يقع
النقاش حول موضوع مره حول الدبابات مره
حول الطائرات اف 16 الان حول هذه الصواريخ
بعيده المدى والكل لاي هدف كل ذلك
دائما هناك منظومه محمد النجاح العسكري
يجب ان يتم القتال فيه من ضمن منظومه يعني
نبدا بالمدفعيه العاديه من عشرين الى 30
كيلومتر الهايمرز الى 80 كم الشادو
250 كيلو متر واليوم اذا تحدثنا عن 300
كيلومتر هذا امر يعطي عمق وبعد اساسي لاي
تقدم عسكري روسي خاصه استهداف على سبيل
المثال شبه جزيره القرم التي هي جزء اساسي
من العمق الروسي اللوجستي ولماذا على سبيل
المثال ايضا ضرب القياده البحريه البحر
الاسود لانه البحر الاسود او اسطول البحر
الاسود هو مكلف بنقل اللوجستيه تحديدا
مندا الروسيه للعمق الاوكراني في الجنوب
اذا اذا كانت بعيده المدى بالمدى الذي
اشرت اليه 300 كيلو متر هل معنى ذلك ان
الحذر او التح فظ الغربي بخصوص استهداف
العمق الروسي الان تقريبا يتلاشى
انا اعتقد هناك خط احمر لدى الرئيس بايدن
من ضمن استراتيجيه كبرى من ضمن الوضوح
الاستراتيجي كما يقال ان لا يتم استهداف
الاراضي الروسيه بذخيره غربيه خاصه اذا
كانت امريكيه من هنا محمد نرى ان كل
المسيرات هي من صنع محلي او من صنع سوفيتي
معدله حتى المسيرات البحريه السطحيه منها
ومنها ما دون تحت المياه التي تستهدف شبه
شديده هي كلها من صنع اوكرانيا حتى صاروخ
الذي استطاع اغراق البارجه موسكو هو معدل
من قبل اوكرانيا شكرا لك العميد الياس حنا
من بيروت